- [Joanna V.O.] This is
not your typical car race.
This is a race to make cars
more like computers, and smartphones,
and the best one to buy.
- No, it doesn't stretch.
I don't want cameras anymore.
I want map.
Please slow down.
Please don't hit the Tesla that we rented.
Are you worried about dongles?
- A little bit, yeah.
- I spent the last month
in search of the perfect EV
for me and my family.
That meant testing five leading options
under $60,000 over the
course of two months.
The Kia EV6,
the Hyundai Ioniq 5,
the Tesla Model Y,
the Volkswagen ID.4,
and the Ford Mustang Mach-E.
After narrowing it down
to three finalists,
I took the remaining three
on a road trip to this racetrack
to pick the best one.
I evaluated them on four features:
Battery life; charging;
infotainment; and semi-autonomous driving.
And yes, I've factored in
other important stuff too,
including safety, handling, and...
Why do you like this car?
- Because it farts.
- Let's go!
- [Joanna V.O.] Lap one, battery life,
or what EV people call "range."
One of the biggest pieces of criteria
I had when selecting cars,
a range of about 300 miles.
To test, I recruited two of my colleagues,
and together we drove the three cars
on the same day,
under the same conditions,
to the same destination.
That destination, Lime Rock Racetrack
in Northern Connecticut,
130 miles north of my home
in New Jersey.
Before we hit the road,
we made sure every car was charged up.
- Every car has to start at 100.
- [Joanna V.O.] And that all
the air condition levels were the same.
Each car was fairly new
with relatively low mileage.
To start, Tesla took the lead
about 30 miles into the drive.
- What percentage are you at
and how many miles does
it say you have left?
- [Adam] I have 94%
and 278 miles.
- [Joanna] I'm on 93% and 266 miles.
- [Joanna V.O.] The Hyundai, however...
- [Nellie] 93%, 240 miles.
- [Joanna V.O.] To be
fair, the Hyundai model
I tested was rated for around
a 260 mile range.
The company says
its rear wheel drive
model would've kept up.
Here's how that played out
for the rest of
the two and a half hour drive.
After being on the road for 75 miles,
Tesla and Ford were neck and neck,
around 210 miles left on the battery.
Hyundai was at 190.
- [Joanna] There it is, Lime Rock Park.
We did it.
- [Joanna V.O.] Finally,
when we arrived at the track,
both the Ford and Tesla had
around 150 miles left to go.
Hyundai was still behind.
Still, because all these
cars can be configured
to hit a similar range,
this lap is a...
- It's a tie.
- [Joanna V.O.] Lap two charging.
This is really where these
cars are like smartphones.
The Tesla uses its own
proprietary charging connector and port.
Apple.
- It's called Lightning.
- [Joanna V.O.] Which it now calls
the "North American charging standard."
It also has its own Tesla chargers,
which are dead simple to use
after you've set up your account
in the app.
- And green!
That's it.
- [Joanna V.O.] Ford,
Hyundai, and those other cars
I tested use the combined charging system,
or CCS port,
which work at different charging stations
from various different companies.
And I found some of those stations
to be, well, unreliable.
- Please work.
- [Joanna V.O.] But
even when they do work,
I found that there are some big issues
with these non-Tesla stations,
which can all be illustrated
in what happened in the beautiful town
of Falls Village.
- Let me tell you a story about
what happened here last night.
- Do you have service?
- We realized that the cars were too low
to drive all the way home.
because we had used them
at the track a lot.
Figured, "Okay, we'll
charge 'em overnight,
"even though it's gonna be slow."
We met SemaConnect,
our not very good friend.
- Why would you be able
to use tap to pay?
No, you've gotta download
their proprietary app.
- [Joanna V.O.] Turns out
SemaConnect was acquired by Blink,
so we had to ultimately
download another app.
A Blink spokesman told me
that SemaConnect's transition
to the Blink network may have caused
an inconvenience for some users.
The company also plans to add
more chargers with credit card readers.
SemaConnect was a slower charger,
or a level two charger,
and it took roughly six hours
to charge the cars from 40% to 100%.
- [Joanna] All right, guys,
take care of each other.
- [Joanna V.O.] DC fast charging,
or what's sometimes referred
to as level three,
can do that in under an hour.
And that's exactly what I did
with the Tesla on the road trip.
I've consistently found it easier
to find Tesla fast chargers,
called "superchargers,"
especially in remote areas.
The good news, Tesla has agreed
to allow other cars
from Ford, GM, and others
to access superchargers in early 2024,
and I think the winner
here is pretty clear.
- The Tesla wins this round.
- [Joanna V.O.] Lap three, infotainment.
Both Ford and Tesla have
similarly sized tablets
that have replaced pretty much
all the buttons, knobs and dials.
Okay, Ford kept this knob
and this 10.2 inch screen
above the steering wheel,
so you can easily see vital information
like how fast you're going.
With the Tesla, I had to look over
to the right to see that information.
Hyundai also has two
screens, like the Ford.
- This display here,
this is teeny tiny compared
to the Mustang and to the Tesla.
Feels like a display for ants.
- [Joanna V.O.] Of
course, it's the software
on those screens that matters most.
Tesla has its own software.
Its navigation system is built
with Google Maps data,
but it's not the Google Maps app.
The media apps,
like Apple Music and Spotify,
are built in.
You just sign into your account
on the screen.
- Play Fall Out Boy, "We
Didn't Start The Fire."
- [Joanna V.O.] And you can
pair your phone via Bluetooth.
Ford and Hyundai have
their own software as well,
which is not as good as Tesla's.
- What is this mess?
This whole navigation feels like 1995,
like a MapQuest situation here.
- [Joanna V.O.] But they
also have Android Auto
and Apple CarPlay.
Specifically, Mustang has...
- Wireless CarPlay.
No wires, check it out.
- [Joanna V.O.] With the
Apple and Google software,
you do lose some of that car
and battery integration,
which really shines in the Tesla.
- So as soon as you route to a charger,
it will say "Preconditioning
battery for fast charging."
The biggest decision I have to make,
"how badly do I want Apple CarPlay?"
2023 baby, no wires.
- [Joanna V.O.] So yeah, for this lap...
- It's a tie,
Tesla and Ford.
- [Joanna V.O.] Lap four,
semi-autonomous driving.
- This is very nerve wracking
when there's traffic.
Small breaths, trusting
Tesla with my life right now.
- [Joanna V.O.] All these cars have active
driving assistance features,
which include adaptive cruise control
and lane centering,
so the car can control the speed
and steering on a highway.
In the Hyundai,
using these features requires...
- Keep hands on steering wheel.
- [Joanna V.O.] But Ford and Tesla have
more capabilities in this area.
Ford's Blue Cruise prompts you
to take your hands off
the wheel on highways.
- Oh God, is it gonna do it?
- [Joanna V.O.] Even for lane changes.
You just press on the turn signal and...
- Okay, it's preparing
for another lane change.
Woo hoo!
All right, it did it, it did it.
Slow down, slow down.
And it slowed down.
- [Joanna V.O.] When you enable
Tesla's enhanced autopilot,
it does tell you to keep your hands
on the wheel at first.
But in my tests, it
behaved just like the Ford.
- All right, let's see
if it'll change lanes.
Oh, it's changing lanes.
Oh boy, okay.
That is not as smooth as the Ford.
There's just one tiny question
to ask yourself here.
Which company are you gonna trust
with your life?
- [Joanna V.O.] That is if you can
actually trust the computer
to do the driving.
Tesla has additional
self-driving features,
but I kept taking over the wheel
when testing them.
- It's gotten off, it's gotten off.
Nope, I got off.
I don't know if it was gonna get off.
I didn't trust it
and I did it.
- [Joanna V.O.] Overall,
I found Ford's Blue Cruise
easier to figure out
and more informative,
and that's really what you want
in a situation where
the computer is your co-pilot.
- It says "Lane change is
not available right now."
The Ford wins this round.
- [Joanna V.O.] As much as I like
the Hyundai's exterior look
and ultra fast battery charging,
when I did find a fast charger,
it wasn't gonna be my next car.
But even after that road trip
and all that track testing,
I didn't have a decision
between the Ford and the Tesla.
Plus, this really did feel
like a more emotional decision
than my next laptop or phone.
So I decided to phone, or Zoom,
a friend who has reviewed
more EVs on YouTube
than I could count.
- Hey, I'm Marques Brownlee, AKA MKBHD.
- What would you consider
if you were deciding
between these two cars?
- I'm not surprised that
these are your two final options,
they're both really good.
I'd be asking you questions, like,
"What are you gonna do with it?"
I literally don't recommend non-Tesla EVs
to people who actually road trip
with any regularity.
So if that's something you plan
on doing more than a few times,
it might be worth it just for that.
- [Joanna V.O.] Given that this is
a second car for my family,
I don't expect I'd road trip more
than two to three times
a year with the EV.
Plus, I'm going to install a home charger,
and next year Ford will be able
to use those Tesla chargers.
But Marques was incredibly helpful
in seeing the bigger picture.
- We saw the curve with
phones go like this
and then sort of even out,
and now they're mature,
and they get a little bump every year.
And I think with cars,
we're right here.
With electric cars,
we're at the beginning.
- So I should lease.
- I leased my first EV
and I have no regrets about that.
I think in three years,
your computer on wheels
will be much better.
- [Joanna V.O.] And that's
what I've decided to do.
Lease a Ford Mustang Mach-E for 36 months,
and I'll buy a CCS to Tesla adapter
when it's available.
Because, well, I've always dreamed
of having a dongle to charge my car.
- And that's the end of my game show.